Shreya first of all welcome to Studio
congratulations an important victory for
you it wasn't the greatest start to the
tournament that difficult game in round
one and yesterday's Miss against Russia
Great opening preparation by the way in
that one but they take us through your
approach going into this round did you
really want to win were you trying to
play a more peaceful game and try to
equalize or would you want to fight so
from the I just prepped based on like
the opening she had online and she
actually played a completely different
opening so I was like basically lost in
the beginning but it turned out pretty
well for me like her playing Knight D5
early I think she was also confused and
I was also pretty confused so I felt
like that helped me get like a pretty
solid position from the beginning but I
think I started to get more confident
with my position I just felt a lot more
comfortable with it and had more play
compared to her so I think with that
like I was able to get a very nice
position and then it was this moment
when she refused the trade of the queens
and she played this move Queen to D1 it
felt a bit passive to our eyes as well
did you feel feel that way as well yeah
I was really shocked she didn't play
that move I thought she was either gonna
go like Rook A2 or even trade I don't
think trading Queens is good but maybe
you're okay too yeah Rook a two as I
thought but I was really I think I might
have made a reaction when she played
Queen D1 I was like oh okay like that's
a move I didn't really expect but I mean
I didn't mind at all I mean it just made
my game a lot more easier absolutely and
you definitely pounced and went on the
attack redirected your focus on the pawn
on F3 and it felt like at this point you
were breaking through
take us through the final moments of
this game starting with this point yeah
I think I was calculating at this point
and I realized if I just protect all the
G7 Pawn threads that I should be
basically pretty secure nice move
neither five
if you go Queen to E2 oh wow I I
definitely did not see I think I was
just like seeing like just simple ways
to kind of protect so I didn't have to
also calculate too much blade safe yeah
so I was thinking okay Rook C7 then I
want to bring my queen to G4 or even
take the G3 pawn and and then I missed
actually Rook H2 but then I found F2
which which I think pretty much ended
the game playing it safe always a great
strategy
Shreya congratulations you're a newcomer
to the Juniors I believe this might also
be your last eligible year as well what
were your goals coming into this event
and I see you also go to Washington
University yeah yeah representing
so yeah I think uh I was just really
excited to play Kevin this was my last
year so I'm like this this is a
tournament I do have to play and I think
given um that I was I'm coming in sliced
like any points I get like I'll take and
I'm just probably excited to just play
my best chess given that I haven't been
too chess focused in the last couple
years so any any points that gain any
good games I gained I I play like I'll
be really excited and how do you combine
your academic career with your chess as
well do you hope that this tournament is
before school starts yeah definitely I
um I'm currently doing research at the
washu med campus so it's kind of nice to
take a little break from research and
it's nice that it's before school starts
I don't have the whole stress of doing
homework or anything and I think
balancing this and chess like chess is
definitely gone a little bit more in the
back but it's still a great relaxer like
I'll still like de-stress with playing
chess and then I'm part of the chess
club or the co-president ever wash your
chess team and then we'll like still do
meetings it's just a great way to like
connect with the washu community and
still be active in the chess sphere
great work congratulations we'll see you
tomorrow of course thank you our
congratulations to Sharia very nicely
done and I know that